To provide a useful service,
businesses need to react
quickly to changing patterns
in user behavior.
Identifying these patterns
involves
processing customer data.
Lots of it.
But as you collect data, more
and more time is spent on
repetitive tasks to
make predictions.
Machine learning may be used
to sort through huge data
sets, but can be very
difficult to set up.
Google's Predictive API employs
our classifiers to do
the heavy lifting for you,
letting you focus on your
project, not algorithmic
nuts and bolts.
Its predictions help you
understand how your market is
trending over time,
allowing you to
tailor your future strategy.
Here's how it works.
Structure your training
data and upload
it to Google Storage.
Train one of our models
on your data set,
using one of our APIs.
Apply the trained model to make
predictions and profit
from the newly-built model to
interpret data as it comes in,
improving results over
time, using our
continually-improving algorithms
to predict your
customers' future
wants and needs.
Or, use one of our hosted
models, built by experts with
data already gathered
and labeled.
If you crave insight into what
your customers may look to
buy, want to interpret
feedback, or wish to
categorize online data, Google's
Predictive API helps
you quickly see data patterns,
and can help you profit from
knowing what customers want
before they even think to ask.